in each other how about I want to launch
a new yeah right now a new segment a
little roast my host boy yes my host
these are the best comments from people
online yeah because I figure we do we've
been dishing it out man and it's time
for us to take a little bit of it do we
dish it out to each other into each
other with no sign of peeps we called
somebody's aunt fat a couple times I
definitely know that cuz I've woken up
at the middle of the night and been like
did we call somebody saying I know I
regret making finally get the owl no I
don't that guy definitely seemed like he
knows something that we don't but I do
regret that guy I remember the older man
or woman that had the AH look like they
was just one shoe on steroids a wallet
that was stretched up and like a de belt
on and last Las Vegas yeah steroids yeah
yeah yeah actually we try my chocolate
buddy yeah yeah grandma yeah
yeah you're right dude yeah it's life
bro
yeah like grandma yeah yeah I don't have
she gamma
don't have no alcohol yeah sure about
that don't submit pictures of Grandma
Lee not some graham crackers and we take
it easy yeah you know who doesn't have
nuts most every grandma okay so every
now and then if one pops through with
some newts bra it's okay it will say
what's up your grandma slides My Damn
with a nuts hanging out I gotta say
something yeah I must spill a little
turtle soup cuz I'm [ __ ] shell shocked
when I see that shit's right but we
wanted to hear from you guys a little
bit uh Derek where do we get these from
these are all fans submission these are
all from the YouTube comments from the
Instagram comments these are all just
the comments for King in the state okay
and it's it's the fans ripping into Theo
and ni yes okay so I'm gonna read one
that's the one about me and I'm read one
by you let's do that yeah yeah let's do
that good with reading or you I can't
help what do you want to do this um call
your mom okay let's let's pretend that
you completed every word in that
sentence first I'll call your mom till
you're trying to read before you pass
out that's a game we play often in here
is her tendon burned and use all the
letters recently in a sentence second of
all I would like to read this one ha ha
I'm just proud of
you can read bro yeah oh uses my old
jokes against you
how's that no joke me what I can read
way better than you dude dude what if
you put a bunch of words in front of us
dude they wouldn't know me way better
than they wouldn't know you know yeah go
ahead dude bro when you open up a book a
lot of the words run to the back of the
book cuz they're like ah [ __ ]
yeah you just read coloring books are
you talking here comes your mama to show
you pictures here comes this mumble B if
I don't do it road hit a dude okay we're
flap to get my dick ovary out on you and
your mom and Derek and cat we want you
guys to decide in the end which one is
the best one of each and the winner
would be whose fans well they're both
our fans but who got roasted worse would
be the winner
right okay who got roasted worse yes
will be the winner and then the best one
from each side roasting you or roasting
me gets maybe a king the stink shirt
will figure it out okay they get
something maybe they get a deep-fried
hamster from you that's fine dude well
you can eat cheap Pig if you go to pur
you can eat cheap pig on the street and
don't send me any images up but you can
do it and I'll say this right now that
Brendan looks like the water buffalo Joe
Rogan's buddy shot in Australia like
dead water buffalo like this big that
there's always like some [ __ ] rich
white guy shot his home just a little
bit of blood yeah and sometimes there's
no bloody just poisoned it yeah just
choked it out this guy Emmanuel Baron
who sent that okay and that was illest
flu illest flu it was fluid that would
spray you know this guy says Theo looks
like a 90s troubled teen that learns to
express his aggression through dance
[Laughter]
just remember your
I can't get enough did you sing him so
bad alright alright
Brendan who sent that one in a manual
beer and brewery told you his name broke
I sorry I forgot his name
Brendan looks like a Special Olympics
coach it got fired for shooting up them
Tisza myth picogram Jamaican bobsled
team boys electric Juicy Juice
Brendan cut those SOS out there in
blackface dude gotta get him Sport eat
up boy a Golden Snitch by Bram to lose
and now it is from guest Stephano
briones so that's straight out of Spain
I guess
Brendan looks like a manager at a local
car audio store the place you go in and
there's always like a car alarm
no I help you with yeah as long as a car
alarm nobody can turn off the guy that's
trying to help ya oh you want to hear
some Nelly that's all the guys the whole
time he's got Jason Aldean you boys want
to hear that do [ __ ] now I guess drop
your tail feathers oh yeah you got money
here come father
she's you hurry dude on the next 9,000
on the manager okay and that was from
North Riya no a hilarious Brendan looks
like a Puerto Rican third baseman that
flexes his ass cheeks for a whole
three-hour game
[Laughter]
damn bro snowflakes in that ass [ __ ]
ball didn't come his way man and that
one was from Drew ski everyone do a
whole episode of this yeah what else we
got get us into something else man get
us out dark hole dude [ __ ] magic
carpet ride
I think Brendan flexing his ass for
three hours yeah that was hilarious that
guy deserves a hamster can't be the best
one who's the guy's name called Drago
make sure he gets a [ __ ] uh ice cream
sandwich with a hamster or whatever the
Trudy that's his name truce broccolini
get your life together